shooting sports for something that were
passed down traditionally my family my
grandfather was a hounds man who taught
my dad and my dad taught my mom and
before I knew what I was going to my
first Olympics and walked out at the
gold medal and now I look back six
Olympics later and I'm still going
strong
Hillsdale I've heard through the
grapevine through various people she's
been really this fantastic place where
people are very like-minded very much
about the Constitution very much about
Second Amendment and very much about
shooting and heritage sport the shooting
sports facility is gorgeous one of the
things that really struck me because I
think coming from LA we don't have all
the openness and how open it is how
beautiful and how well maintained as
well as the facility itself and all the
different things that they offer in the
forms of shooting from sporting clays
the five standard ski to bunker I mean
it really is impressive I have to say I
am blown away not only at the facility
but what they're doing here and the
future that they're making for the
shooting sports and for the kids
[Music]